exactly is mom's new job she's an
advocate for superheroes but I thought
superheroes were still illegal things
haven't spiraled out of control the
moment I left looks normal to me I'll be
there
No
hey little baby pigs are seem credible
to you get tickets now
well what do you say if I told you you
were gonna be my first love she totally
wants you man polish likes my body
anyway
I feel different around you than I deal
with the guys come on hope so I can be
myself more
what happened at Makani and there ain't
no change in that
my history is all still there
sleep with me in what don't be stupid
just sleep next to no real man chooses
some chick his best buds I don't know
what's going on you
all I want to do is just be a kid don't
forget that part of you okay
you'll wake up one day and you realize
that your parents are just as crazy and
as tough as we are hi grace you uh
teaching our boy the ways of the world
shut up you shut up are you two gonna
leave yes we were just getting started
and I'd really like to get back to it
[Music]
I know you say that again under arrest
for the murder of Rolla Legrand get the
wrong guy I was with her oh come on
let's go and that this is a frame-up
hey pop you're right
money get some never escape without it
Louie they got nice a millionaire last
long
[Music]
[Music]
keep me alive
I'll underwrite I didn't escape you can
you arrange something tells me you can
do quite Savage
you are the property of the penal
administration of French Guiana there's
no way off snows away I know many of you
are thinking about escape this is your
best shipment feel free to try whenever
you like I'm gonna come with you there
are two Guardians who are always Beauty
bushed
what a best thing that can happen to you
with starvation or you could choose to
see what's it go white sharks always and
you managed to survive your first
attempt you'll get two years in solitary
second attempt you'll get a life
sentence at Devil's Island
strange things happen there especially
to those who came to help
fire girl and in a different kind of
life
[Music]
[Music]
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual
like in any way enemy we saw something
oh yeah then you men someone or
something torn to pieces I think they're
attempting hybridization they're
upgrading on every planet they visit we
need to know if you pose a threat
we're assassins there's imposing the
threat kind of deployed
[Music]
not only haven't stories about the
jungle I lifted the king's palace in a
case just like this I bet I scratched
and I spent my entire life fighting
until one day I just stopped and I
gained their trust gained their trust
little brother
[Music]
the jungle is no longer safe for you
you must and the village
it'll be all right little brother when I
found you all seasons ago I thought I
couldn't teach you how to belong
but I was wrong luckily how you grow
[Music]
[Music]
you were ago
I looked you in the eye so no fear
I believe that one day he would bring
peace to the jungle
but you have become a man
[Music]
I'm not a man
but neither am i oh whoa
[Music]
I think we can both agree mowgli that
you are something the jungle has never
seen before
it's been whispers
he's got our commoners looking up seeing
hope
if I may
I've proposed a bounty a thousand a week
until he's caught okay
I've never seen anything like you
and stared death in the face that's why
I chose you
you're not curious
there's another hood
he's obviously well-trained
you flatter him he's a smash-and-grab er
nothing more do you think the thief is
he's all of us
biron and Marva he has his qualities
he's not you know you sure
you're a crusader
now
you have to be a warrior
you wanted to steam
what's that supposed out yeah of course
so how long have you been Antonin again
no uh and just sort of happened oh it's
like bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a person
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be ghosts
and like walks through walls and stuff
so Leo tech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever who would have
believed that in your hour of need you
would turn the house happy because we
robbed you do you remember that's us
feeling chance we practice both the deal
and the wasp teaming up
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you two
are finished comparing sizes 65 do you
want to live in a world where everybody
feels cozy and validates all the time
what do you want to live in a world that
works we fight new wars the old options
military diplomacy
they don't always succeed
sometimes you need a third option that's
overwatch according to the government we
do not exist for those who we are very
real and we get [ __ ] done only gonna
help on this one fun nine pounds of
radioactive isotope is missing it's
enough to make six major cities
uninhabitable he knows exactly where it
is what do you want I want out of the
country cuz one set for espionage we're
talking about a corrupt low-level cop so
you're sitting here indicates he's nuts
or low-level you [ __ ] be careful
do you have men wandering our embassy
and I just put me on the plane to the US
and it gives you everything to go
there's no water free the goal is
deliver that package to here mile 22 you
know he can't mrs. guys me Bob what
about to go through
like cuz I can't cheat them
concentration contact
requesting hand of God got it take it
Wow our angel can only stay on the
ground two minutes they miss that window
they are dead
if you come to names you tell us all
that the game today I'll plant
everything I've seen maybe
last four please frame on my history I
think I might be worse I am killer who
looks like a hero right
you feeling calm Alice not even a little
are you I'm totally calm that's because
you're mentally unstable thank you
there's never been a black cop in this
city we think you might be the man to
open things up around here oh this is
Ron starwolf called Oh Who am I speaking
with this is David Duke Grand Wizard of
the Ku Klux Klan that David dude God
last time I checked what can I do for
him well since you asked I hate blacks
I hate Jews Mexicans and Irish Italians
and Chinese but my mouth to God's ears I
really hate those black brats and anyone
else really that doesn't have pure white
Aryan blood running through their veins
I'm not gonna be talking to a true white
American god bless white America the KKK
is planning an attack how do you propose
to make this investigation well
establish contact over the phone we'll
need a white officer to play me when
they meet face to face before the white
race Ron oh how I know so there becomes
a combined Ron stall work can you do
that with the right white man we can do
anything
[Music]
where's the last time they let it rookie
leader the best suggestion oh that's
right never okay become his friend
let's get invited back what kind of
stuff you guys know cross burnings
marches this is fixed it'll be a big
year for us that's too many questions
the undercover or something
because tonight they've organized to
fight racism are you down for the
liberation of black people power to the
people
all power to all the people that's right
system for you it's a crusade for me
it's a job you're Jewish
that hatred doesn't that piss you off
you're taking this jewel I detector test
why are you acting like you ain't got
skin in the game I'm telling you the
Wars at Commons Knights of the Ku Klux
Klan that's us Stallworth brothers baby
America first fella know this is a fan
mean I would have taken this love that's
a nice dress
thank you I like your jacket
Thanks our flights on time
it is great I'm sorry what was that
what you just took a step forward there
I didn't yeah you did you know you did
and if what's funny is there's no way
you can board first because the only way
you the board for us is to be a special
need do you have a special need yes I
need to be over there and going to that
destination wedding myself Tony
experiment so we're just the people you
don't know how to stick you might as
well just stick us together
I don't want to be a person you don't
know where to stick destination buddy is
presumptuous there in a fool's paradise
you believe there's someone for everyone
close I believe that there's nobody for
anyone
I understand how even after Keith did
what he did to you can possibly still be
mooning over because you're a monkey who
doesn't understand the human condition
having met you I understand why it's a
condition
you know I'm not wearing anything under
my pajamas why would you they're so
alluring
[Music]
what is that I think it's a mountain
lion could it be a Jaguar what
difference does it make mm-hmm the
Cougar may be jesus course
[Music]
how do you not install a pathway the
heels won't make it can you carry me
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]